The general can experience now that it's done. Uh, and you,
you go back and you look at it and you,
you think about the time that's passed since you released it.
Is there anything that you would have revised?
Is there anything that you wish you would, uh, added?
Yeah. Um, I, you know, a lot of it,
I think stands a lot of this stuff is still true. It holds,
holds the same, uh, swipe with me. Uh, I still endorse it.
I really,
really struggled to get behind the curtain of the big tech companies.
And I wanted to write about the business side of,
of what these companies were doing and, um, tried really hard,
but didn't get that far in delving with these companies. Um,
I couldn't get past a lot of the, kind of,
there were some barriers and I knew what I was writing about because I wanted to
be honest about it.
And I couldn't get a lot of the information that I wish I had been able to get.
Now, when I speak about it, I have a lot of that information.
I would have folded it into the book. A lot of it's not in there. I mean,
I still talk about what these companies are doing. Um,
but I would like to have known more about the business side and a lot of that
was hidden from me. So that's a big part of it. Um, there's not,
there's not much else really. I I'm, I have a PhD in psychology.
And so I'm interested in what makes people tick and how they think.
And so the middle big chunk of the book is these,
these different hooks that are embedded in these platforms that make it hard for
us to resist them. And that hasn't changed. Um, that's as true as ever.
And so I don't feel that I would change anything about that part of the book.
What about the, the business practices of, uh,
these companies was interesting to you that they are aware of
how addictive all these things are?
Yeah. I,
one of the practices I found fascinating was the extent to which these companies
use massive datasets to make their decisions and huge amounts of data.
So, you know, there,
there are two ways to make smart decisions when you're designing a product.
The one way is you,
you speak to smart people who know a lot about humans and what makes them tick
their motivations. And then you,
you take that information and you embedded in the platform that you're
designing,
but that's really hit and miss that's how a lot of video game development
worked. And again, speaking to these video game experts,
who've designed games that have made tons of money who have been very
successful. A lot of them will say, look, I created a lot of games,
but you know, a lot of them missed the Mark.
I had a couple that were great successes,
but for every two that were successful, there were 10 that weren't.
So there's a lot of kind of trial and error.
What the big tech companies do in large part is they avoid the trial and error
by being completely agnostic about the theory of what's going to drive us.
They don't need to know about that.
All they need to do is run a series of kind of trials by combat.
So if you're playing again, world of Warcraft fortnight,
what I do is I throw to two different versions of a particular mission up and
half the players will play one version.
The other half will play the other version that say, one of them is by,
is through a forest. The other one's identical. You have to do the thing,
but you're going by the ocean. The question is, what effect does that happen?
You might discover people will play the mission 10 minutes longer if they're by
the ocean. So then you say, okay, we're going to privilege ocean missions.
So now we have two versions of the ocean mission.
This is round two of the trial.
You can either rescue an artifact or you can rescue a person.
And people are turns out, are more interested in rescuing a person.
So they'll play for an extra 10 minutes. If you do this,
this kind of trial by combat round. After round after round,
you're revolving a weaponized version of the platform.
So you keep selecting the version. That's hardest for us to resist.
And if you do that on mass, it ends up shaping the user experience.
You end up having features on the platform that are designed to be hard for us
to escape from. Um, if you're creating a game, you, you released the version.
That's most difficult for us to resist. Now, of course,
forever people who are writing movies or books or any form of entertainment,
we're trying to do this. They just were much less good at it.
What the tech companies do is they make this kind of a sure thing by having
access to billions and billions of data points and getting real time,
very rapid feedback from us.
Isn't it also to compare it to books and movies.
It's not a fair comparison because those things end. Yes,
that's really where the problem lies, right?
Is that a book or a movie is not going to make you eat pizza three times a
day and gained 40 pounds over five weeks because you're trapped in your house
doing nothing but enjoying this book or movie constantly,
because there is no end to it. Like there's something
like, I, I completely understand why they would do that. I mean, it makes sense.
You're engineering a game you would want to make this game the most compelling,
the most entertaining the, the, the, the, the most, uh,
engaging possible.
But do you think that these companies have a social responsibility for
recognizing the fact that they are massively addictive?
Do I have an ethical and social responsibility? Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely.
I think they do. I think, I think that the biggest problem,
the most broken part of all of this is, is the incentive model.
So all of these platforms pretty much reliant on,
I'm thinking about Google, Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, these platforms require your eyeballs for as many minutes of the day as
possible. And every minute that you're not spending on that device,
you're spending minutes doing other things that is a loss.
They conceive of that as a loss.
And it is because it means that less capable of attracting advertising dollars.
And that drives the whole model. That is a broken model.
It's a terrible model because it privileges extracting minutes of time over
delivering well-being. Now,
historically products were largely if I made a great product,
like when you played, um, I think you said it was quite right real quick.
What do you play quake? When I play doom,
when I played super Mario as a younger kid than that, when Nintendo came out,
that was just an incredible product. I think that was just, you know,
there was designed to deliver a phenomenal A-plus top class experience.
And when you speak to the video game developers, there's a,
purism a purity to it. Um, you know, the, the,
the creator of Mario and the creator of Tetris submitted all of these games,
they all talk about the kind of love that went into the creating these games
that's gone. This is not about making us happier,
giving us a good experience and experience that we're willing to part with our
money for it's all one big kind of heist there. They're trying to trick us.
They're trying to basically get us to part with our time and therefore without
money. And yes, there's an ethical responsibility. I mean, if you,
if you see this at an industrial company and this company is making billions of
dollars, but there are major externalities. So negatives that come with that,
let's say the spearing crap into the waterways and into the air.
That's something that, you know, for the last 25, 30 years or so,
the government has said, you know, that's not okay.
We're going to penalize you for that.
I'm not suggesting they do exactly the same thing with tech companies,
but there is an externality. These companies are making billions of dollars.
The externality is not that they're poisoning the waterways and the air,
but they're changing how we live our lives. And I'd argue in many ways,
for the worse.
Do you think, uh,
a warning label would have the same sort of effect that a warning label has on
cigarettes? Like it doesn't really matter.
Like when they put those cancer labels on cigarettes,
people that smoke cigarettes already know it causes cancer.
I don't think it stops anything or helps them at all.
Warning labels are toothless. They only work. If you don't know, you know,
is they're educating you. And everyone knows, everyone knows about cigarettes.
I mean, fighting, fighting tobacco addiction is really difficult with,
with both with smokers and with young people who are thinking about smoking,
it's going to be the same with these devices. I think no one needs what may be.
Maybe there's slightly more room to educate people about these things with
respect to, to screen time and what we're doing on screens.
But most of us know this stuff and warning labels don't do much.
I agree.
So what could they do?
You're not gonna have them hamstring themselves and make a game that's less
addictive. Like if you like, let's propose,
they reverse engineer what they've done and do it the opposite way.
Like it's going towards the ocean, makes people play more.
So we're going to go to the woods, rescuing a person makes you play more.
So you're gonna, you a rescue, a gem, you know,
like they're going to choose the least addictive out of all of these paths.
Then you're going to be non-competitive with the people that are engineering
games that are going to choose the most addictive.
So then it's almost like everyone's agreeing to make the game possible because
that's the only way people can not be addicted.
It's true. I mean, there's, there's no way in, uh,
in the arms race for our attention and, uh, you know,
our dollars and all that sort of stuff. No, one's going to buy into this idea.
We should make a version of the product. I think,
as I said, the model is broken.
If the model is about attention and about picking the version of the game,
that's going to extract the most time that's, that's problematic to begin.
Um, it would be better if there were a way to, to basically create a model that,
that prizes consumer welfare, which then translates into people,
wanting to part with their dollars. I don't know,
that's obviously difficult to do in practice, but you know,
a lot of industries work that way.
It just so happens that the model we chose for it in particular social media,
this is not as true for games, but for social media, for sure. Um,
we are the product and our eyeballs are the product. Um,
and the consumer is the big industry of companies that are buying ads on those
platforms. So, you know, these,
the reason they're free is because they need our eyeballs,
but you could imagine an alternate universe where,
where you had to pay a small annual fee to use these products,
but there was no advertising.
And so the money came from revenue from the billions of dollars of revenue that
you got from, from individual users who are paying to use the platform.
And that's,
that's a universe that I think leads to better outcomes for everyone and
designing features based on people, enjoying them,
getting value from them rather than features designed to hook us. But I, I mean,
I, I've been thinking about this for it's now six or seven years,
and I am, I I'm just as exasperated.
And that's why I think a lot of the focus now has to be on the individual
consumer. If you're a consumer who needs help with this,
you spending too much time.
You feel bad about it when let's talk about ways to deal with it.
But working at the level of the, of the tech companies is, is really,
really difficult.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere, but after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking. Just go download Spotify much, Bubba.